if I were president the first thing I
would do is probably get sat down by the
Pentagon and the powers that be who
would say no you're probably not going
to get done the things that you we saw
you're one sheet and you're not going to
get it I think a lot of presidents going
with a big to-do list and someone sits
them down and says that's really not how
the game is played son you're going to
have to learn this is the beltway we do
things a certain way he had high hopes
and you'll get a few of these things
done
watered down neutered and relatively
meaningless by the time they crawl
through the Senate but as it is now
these big burly strong changes no so I
would probably be told that because my
first day in office I would have lost
Don't Ask Don't Tell I would have
reestablished glass-steagall I would
have demanded that the Bush tax cuts
they would have sunsetted they would
have gone away there would have been
some pain that the middle class would
have been hard up against it but we
would be in a much different position
than we are now so I would have gone in
reacting to eight years of George W Bush
two useless wars that make America
hemorrhage life and treasure I would
immediately start repairing the
perception of America in the world like
our president did by speaking out in
Cairo to basically Islam so I would do
things like that realizing my first four
years in office would be to repair and
somehow neutralize the eight years that
came before me so maybe in my next term
I could go slowly upfield to a
noticeable degree and that would be my
legacy first four years clean up the
storm you know clean up the wreckage
make nice with the world demilitarize as
far as American military presence in the
world I would get my military force out
of the like 141 countries that we're in
plus all the black bases we have
off the record I would bring these
people home